OUT INCORRECT INFORMATION
INCLUDING MY CALL WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE WHICH WAS A
PERFECT HOLE.
>> Sean: HERE WITH REACTION
SENATE JUDICIARY LINDSEY GRAHAM.
SENATOR, I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED
ABOUT TWO FELLOW COLLEAGUES.
JOHN CORNYN OF TEXAS AND
MITCH McCONNELL, YOUR LEADER,
SAYING WE'VE GOT TO HAVE NOT 51
VOTES TO DISMISS THIS SHAM
PROCESS AND THEN McCONNELL
KIND OF SEEMINGLY BACKING HIM
UP, WAIT A MINUTE.
IF THERE IS NO DUE PROCESS,
AFFORDED BILL CLINTON HIS
ATTORNEYS, THE DEMOCRATS, THEY
ARE GOING TO TAKE THIS UP ANYWAY
IN THE SENATE?
>> WELL, HERE IS THE TRAIL IS IN
THE SENATE.
LET'S SAY THEY GET 218 VOTERS.
HERE IS WHAT I PROMISED THE
COUNTRY.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TRY THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
BASED ON HEARSAY.
IN THE RESOLUTION SETTING UP A
TRIAL AND THE SENATE COME I WILL
MAKE SURE THAT HEARSAY CANNOT BE
THE BASIS OF IMPEACHMENT
ALLEGATION.
IF YOU INVOKE THE HEARSAY RULE,
WHAT WOULD BE LEFT?
>> Sean: I MEAN, IT IS A GREAT
QUESTION.
I WAS SURPRISED, ESPECIALLY
CONSIDERING YOU SAID IT WAS DOA
WITHOUT THE WHISTLE-BLOWER,
WITHOUT DUE PROCESS.
WE HAVE NONE OF THAT.
>> CAN I BUILD THIS?
A TRIAL IN THE SENATE TO ME
MEANS SHOULD NOT LEGITIMIZE WHAT
IS GOING ON IN THE HOUSE.
NO AMERICAN IS DENIED THE RIGHT
TO CALL WITNESSES ON THEIR
BEHALF EXCEPT DONALD TRUMP.
NO AMERICAN IS ACCUSED OF
WRONGDOING ANONYMOUSLY EXCEPT
DONALD TRUMP.
THAT THEY ARE DOING IN THE HOUSE
HAS A DANGER TO THE PRESIDENCY
ITSELF.
SO WHEN A TRIAL IN THE SENATE
NEEDS TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU YOU
CAN'T IMPEACH A PRESIDENT BASED
ON HEARSAY BECAUSE THAT IS A
DANGER TO THE PRESIDENCY ITSELF.
SECONDLY, IN A TRIAL IN THE
SENATE MUST EXPOSE A
WHISTLE-BLOWER SO THE PRESIDENT
CAN CONFRONT HIS ACCUSER.
I WILL NOT ACCEPT A TRIAL IN THE
SENATE UNTIL I KNOW WHO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER IS.
>> Sean: SO, A LOT OF THE
HEARSAY HEARSAY, HEARSAY,
HEARSAY COME UP FOR A WAY
HEARSAY WAY HEARSAY WENT BACK TO
THE
TESTIMONY IN
PRIVATE AS THEY WERE
AUDITIONING AND CHERRY PICKING
THE WITNESSES, BUT THEY KEEP
REFERRING TO THE AMBASSADOR
SONDLOND WHO SAID THE PRESIDENT
CLEARLY STATED I WANT NO QUID
PRO QUO.
WE KNOW VOLKER TESTIFIED HE DID
NOT RECEIVE INDICATION OF ANY
QUID PRO QUO.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY, THERE WAS
ZERO PRESSURE.
THREE MEETINGS WITH THESE GUYS
AND THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE,
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY, HE NEVER DID
ANYTHING, AND HE STILL GOT THAT
AID.
I'M LIKE, SO WHERE IS THE SQUID
AND THE PRO AND THE QUOTE.
HELP ME OUT.
>> THEY GOT THE MONEY AND NOBODY
INVESTIGATED JOE BIDEN AND THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT.
SO THERE IS NO THERE THERE.
BUT LET'S GO BACK TO THE IDEA
WHAT KIND OF TRAIL WOULD YOU
CONDUCT?
IF YOU EXCLUDED HEARSAY LIKE
EVERY OTHER COURT IN THE LAND,
THERE IS NOTHING THEY ARE.
AND IF YOU ALLOW THE PRESIDENT
TO APPROACH HIS ACCUSER COME YOU
HAVE TO CALL THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
HERE IS A QUESTION I HAVE ABOUT
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
IT WAS THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
CONNECTED TO JOE BIDEN IN ANY
WAY?
DID THE WHISTLE-BLOWER GIVE
HIMSELF OR GET HIMSELF INVOLVED?
HERE IS THE POINT I'M TRYING TO
MAKE.
HERE IS THE POINT.
DID THE WHISTLE-BLOWER ENGAGE IN
AN EFFORT TO GET THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT TO WEIGH IN AND STOP
THE INVESTIGATION OF THIS GAS
COMPANY?
WAS THERE A CONNECTION BETWEEN
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER AND BIDEN'S
EFFORT TO COAL UKRAINE?
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME.
WE CANNOT LEGITIMIZE AN
IMPEACHMENT BASED ON AN
ANONYMOUS SOURCE IF YOU DO THAT,
NO PRESIDENT WILL BE ALLOWED
TO SURVIVE.
AND THE FELLOW MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BE IN THE SHOES OF DONALD TRUMP?
YOU ARE ACCUSED OF SOMETHING
BASED ON A WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO IS
ANONYMOUS AND YOU CANNOT CALL
WITNESSES ON YOUR BEHALF.
>> Sean: NOW COME I HAVE FOUND
EVIDENCE OF A QUID PRO QUO.
QUID PRO QUO JOKE.
BECAUSE HE SAYS TO UKRAINE IN A
SHAKEDOWN, "YOU ARE NOT GETTING
THE BILLION DOLLARS UNLESS YOU
FIRE THAT PROSECUTOR" FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR AND YOU GET THE
BILLION.
DON'T FIRE THE PROSECUTOR, YOU
DON'T GET THE BILLION.
WHO IS THE PROSECUTOR?
THE PROSECUTOR IS THE GUY HE WAS
TOLD IS INVESTIGATING HIS SON,
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER BEING
PAID MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
NOW, THAT SEEMS LIKE A QUID AND
A PRO AND A QUOTE.
WE ACTUALLY FOUND ONE.
WHY IS THERE A ZERO INTEREST
THESE PEOPLE THAT CLAIM THIS IS
SO BAD THE QUID PRO QUO IS SO
BAD, CLAIMED ELECTION
INTERFERENCE IS BAD.
WE HAVE EVIDENCE OF BOTH HERE
EXCEPT NOT ON THEIR SIDE.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT GETTING TO
THE TRUTH.
IT IS ABOUT DESTROYING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
ADAM SCHIFF IS NOT AN
INDEPENDENT PERSON HERE.
MUELLER AND EVERYBODY ELSE
INVOLVED IN IMPEACHMENT IN THE
PAST WERE OUTSIDE OF POLITICS.
HERE IS MY POINT.
DID THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE,
THE PREVIOUS PRESIDENT DID HE
RECEIVE A CALL FROM JOE BIDEN
AND WAS THAT CALL RELATED TO THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE GAS COMPANY
THAT HUNTER BIDEN WAS SITTING
ON?
I WILL WRITE IT IF NOBODY ELSE
WILL A LETTER TO THE PRESIDENT
OF UKRAINE.
DID YOU EVER GET A CALL FROM
JOE BIDEN CALLING OFF THE DOGS
REGARDING THIS GAS COMPANY?
>> Sean: THE COMPROMISED
CONGENITAL LIAR SCHIFF, CALL
MEMBERS OF THE STAFF ABOUT THE
CONTACT OF THE WHISTLE-BLOWER.
WILL THE WHISTLE-BLOWER BE
FORCED TO TESTIFY IN THE SENATE?
WHAT ABOUT HUNTER AND JOE BIDEN?
WILL ALL OF THAT HAPPEN?
>> GREAT QUESTION.
AS A MATTER OF A VOTER SIDE COME
I WILL NOT CALL THE HOUSE.
BUT IF YOU IMPEACH THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES COME I WANT
TO FIND OUT, IF, IN FACT, SCHIFF
AND HIS STAFF MET WITH A
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
IF YOU SAID TODAY IS THAT TRUE.
IF THERE IS A TRIAL IN THIS AND
THAT, ONE OF THE WITNESSES WILL
BE ADAM SCHIFF BECAUSE IF HE
DID, IN FACT MEET WITH THE